it's a remarkable photo documents
recovered by the fbi from its raid on
the florida home of former president
donald trump some marked in bright red
or yellow top secret and if you look
closely others marked hcs highly
classified papers which could have
details on american spies or secret
human sources
the august 8th raid came after repeated
efforts by the authorities to have
trump's team return documents taken when
he left the white house trump's lawyers
claimed they had made a diligent search
and they had nothing that needed to be
returned but the raid uncovered more
than a hundred classified documents not
just in the storage area at mar-a-lago
but in the ex-president's desk the
filing stating that government records
were likely concealed and removed and
that efforts were taken to obstruct the
government's investigation the idea that
he didn't know he was holding on to
classified information they were sitting
in his desk in his office not just in
the storage room it's very hard to make
the argument
on truth social the ex-president's
social media channel he offered up a
line of defense
terrible the way the fbi during the raid
of mar-a-lago threw documents
haphazardly all over the floor perhaps
pretending it was me that did it and
then started taking pictures of them for
the public to see thought they wanted
them kept secret lucky i declassified
but while running for president in 2016
he attacked hillary clinton's handling
of sensitive documents insisting no one
was above the law my administration
i'm going to enforce all laws concerning
the protection of classified information
some of what was recovered from
mar-a-lago was so sensitive according to
the court filing even the fbi
counter-intelligence personnel and dog
attorneys conducting the review required
additional clearance before they were
permitted to review certain documents
trump's team have filed a request for a
special master an independent set of
eyes saying the fbi seized documents to
which they had no legal right but the
department of justice says all the
documents have now been reviewed that
none need to be returned because they
belong to the government not to one
individual and that donald trump never
declassified them and that is what could
put the ex-president and his team at
legal jeopardy
alan fisher al jazeera at the department
of justice in washington